You've mentioned a few times as we've
discussing this that historians like to
ignore this. Historians like to ignore
that or they paint this one-sided
picture and the way you actually
describe it is that the one-sided
picture they paint is the opposite of
what is true. I'm curious about what you
think the motivation is
>> by those historians.
>> I think there's several. I think today
it's just it's it's kind of, you know,
it's snowballed and it's just that's the
narrative. So if you're just a
moderately ed if you go to college today
and you're a history major and you're
studying this field you're not going to
read primary sources which you should
that used to be the original thing
you're supposed to but go read this you
know three four books by the secondary
secondary his uh source would be you
know like me okay a modern person who
supposedly consults the primary sources
and then you know [snorts] puts it into
a book form and you read it so most
people will read that and those books
now you know they and they've been going
and and the question is but have
[snorts] painted a completely different
picture. You know, a guy like Sir Steven
Runsman, for example, who's the he wrote
like four or five volumes of the
Crusades and it was considered, you
know, the best seller, etc., etc. I
think came out maybe the 50s or 60s.
And now historians will tell you, yeah,
this guy really had an axe to grind, you
know, and he was just dedicated to
making the Christians look bad and
making the Muslims look good, right? And
how do we know this? because the ones
who have taken the time to consult the
primary sources are realizing what he's
saying is not there and often times the
opposite is there. So why okay the
reason why um I would argue today it's
because of what we would call political
correctness. It's this desire honestly,
okay, really to bring it down where you
know the narrative has to always be this
Christians, whites are bad,
non-Christians, brown people are good.
Okay, this is it. That's the mantra and
everything has to conform to this.
>> Why? Okay, we can get into that. But
that has been the case for I would say a
long time since the 60s. Okay. Um, and
the sort of self-hatred thing has arose.
But, you know, there's also other
reasons, you know, academic reasons. For
example, you want to be a historian,
okay? The the thing that would make you
popular is you come up with a new
interpretation.
So, for the longest time, the
interpretation was what I'm telling you.
But if I can come up with something
clever, like, oh wait, actually, and
Lucio is a great beacon of light and
learning. Okay, wow. Then I've made a
new contribution. Especially if it's
what people want to hear. People want to
hear that narrative for the reasons I
just explained. They don't want to hear
about, okay, Christians and Muslims
fighting because Muslims are aggressors,
etc. M
>> so all of these um but you know again
today in the current climate it's just
you know what I'm saying right now I
don't care how my books sword and
scimitar has like over a thousand
citations endnotes to show you where I
got my stuff cuz I already knew I'm
going to be attacked where'd you get
that where'd you get that so the facts
are there but you know people just they
still till this very day want to believe
that narrative okay which and you see it
everywhere manifestations of what I just
said this narrative even if you're
watching the news and there's some kind
of incident or criminal activity between
a black man and a white man or
something. It has to be spun a certain
way. So of course it's been going on
with history because you know history
people talk about fake news and it's
very important obviously but to me fake
history is more important because fake
news is ephemeral and it you know
creates its mischief but then it you
know vanishes and we move on something
else. Fake history you create
overarching narratives and and um you
know basically paradigms where you sift
reality through. So if I've created a
fake history where you know Muslim
Christian relations are such that
Christians were the evil aggressors and
Muslims were the poor guys. Well of
course now when you talk about anything
in the modern era and you see it through
that lens it all makes perfect sense and
gives you more reason to despise the
Christians and the westerners etc. And
that's what's been going on for a long
time. Which is why I think when I
discuss these things, you know, the
number one response I get from people is
like, I'm embarrassed. I didn't know
this. You know, why didn't I learn this
in school? And well, I'm this is why you
not you didn't because there's a
narrative.
>> Fake news has a political agenda than
fake history. It's the agenda. It's more
profound, but it's still somewhat
political, right?
>> Yeah. Of course, it is political and it
it manifests itself ultimately in a
political way, but it's very subtle and
it's harder to prove. And you know, so
fake news, we can argue, oh, here's
evidence that this guy didn't say,
whatever. But fake history, you know,
who's going to take the time to delve
into the primary sources like let's say
I did and I did it cuz I love it and I
was at the Library of Congress and I had
access to all those books and I know a
couple of languages, you know, so it's
not that easy to do that. and you're
just going to go by if I go to the
bookstores, Barnes & Nobles for example,
um, and I go to the Middle East or a
history section, all the books, and I'm
familiar with them, they're all the
politically correct books that say the
exact opposite of what I'm telling you.
>> Yeah.
>> So, if you mean well and you want to
read a book and you educate yourself and
you go to Barnes & Nobles, you're just
going to
>> you're going to you're going to you're
going to learn the exact opposite. And
that's why I always find it funny that
you're better off being ignorant.
Because if you're ignorant, if you're an
un unlearned, learned person, maybe just
dropped, you know, high school and you
didn't go to college, you're probably
going to have a better understanding of
what we're talking about from an
instinctual level at least.
>> Yeah.
>> But if you go the further you go to
higher education and formally study
these things,
>> what happens is the le you learn the
exact opposite, but then you're proud of
it and you're so visous about you know
because I got a degree. I know what I
know this. You don't know what you're
talking about. But what happened is
you've been indoctrinated in lies.
>> Yeah. So look, you've mentioned a couple
of books that have changed the popular
understanding of let's say the crusades
and these very various other moments.
But would you could you pinpoint to a
specific moment in time when the
narrative changed from as you described
earlier there was a common understanding
in Europe about Islam aggression in
Europe to
>> now where most would have no idea. Is
there a moment in time where that
>> the transitional phase? Yeah, which is a
good good question. So, okay, honestly,
it all really starts with and and a lot
of people don't like to hear this, but
the with the Protestant Reformation,
okay, because with the break with the
Catholic Church was a need to, you know,
I don't want to use the word demonized,
but whatever, you know, justify the
break. And so, anything the Catholic
Church did became jaundest and kind of
bad, including the crusades. And, you
know, the Protestants made good points,
you know, indulgences, etc., etc. I get
that. That makes sense. But you you got
this move now where like whatever we
can, you know, however we can make
Catholics look bad, we should. And that
was the beginning. So Martin Luther, he
condemned the Crusades. And then he
condemned when the Turks were actually
invading Vienna or coming towards
Austria, he actually said, "Don't fight
back." And and he said, "This is God's
way of punishing the Catholics and
church." until they got close to where
he was and he actually changed his tomb
literally and wrote a new saying no you
can fight back. It is just war. This is
not [laughter] I'm not lying to you.
This is true. I can give you the
evidence.
>> How's that for motivated reasoning?
>> Yeah. So [laughter] so it really starts
with a prot and look I'm not people I'm
not I don't want to get into the I'm not
a theologian. I'm not arguing who's
right theologically. I'm just saying as
a historical development the rift
between in Christendom between
Protestants and Catholics created a sort
of hatred towards the crusades. Okay.
because it was another thing to point at
and say, "Oh, look." And then and they
also this is was also the the beginning
of the rehabilitation of of Muslims in
the eyes of Europeans because if Muslims
are the enemies of the bad guys, the
Catholics, they must be good. Okay? And
this is why till today it's actually
Protestant nations that are suffering
from Islam because they're the ones who
have completely opened their doors and
who who follow this logic which is m
Muslims are great. It's the Catholics
you got to worry about. Okay? or or at
least elements of it still
subconsciously maybe exist. Um that's
why you have Muslims running a muck in
Scandinavia and Sweden and the UK and in
Germany. Um then but then you look at
countries like uh you know Hungary and
Poland which is you know Hungary I know
is Catholic and co and so is Poland and
you don't see that sort of thing as much
of course and I think that's a u so
anyway that's the beginning of it. I
would say the Protestant Reformation and
again this isn't me I'm not talking
about theology. I'm talking about
historical development, which is normal,
of course. Um, and then you get the
Enlightenment, right? And with the
Enlightenment, all of a sudden now, now
there's a kind of it's not that the
Muslims are good, but yeah, these
Christians are fanatics. This is now
Edward Gibbon, for example, um, is
Voltater and these guys it so now once
again, the the crusaders and their calls
looks ridiculous and they're stupid and
what are they fighting over? This is
dumb, etc. Okay. And then you move on
until you come to sort of the modern,
you know, 19th century, 1800s. Now you
have serious scholars, orientalists, and
um you know, they just approach it in a
very cold fashion that are I I actually
like their writings. They're objective,
okay? And they're looking at the sources
and um they're actually better than the
other guys, but you still have the
influence of the sort of, you know, the
Protestant disdain for crusades and you
have the, you know, the enlightenment
disdain as well. Um and then you come
into the modern era where again, I think
it's this need, you know, we comes from,
you know, I want to
I think sometime in the 60s you get this
move this very anti-Christian thing
where you know Christians and Europeans
and Westerners are the root of all
problems. Okay. And of course this is
how the crusades been. So now it's being
taught that way and you know we're
gravitating back. So now it's worse than
ever because what they're doing is
they're lit literally playing with
history. I already gave you an example
of all the horrors that happened before
the first crusade. In one year 30,000
churches were destroyed. This is say
nothing of the killings of Christians
under Hakim Bamaha the Fatimid Khif or
all the other ones and they ignore all
that intentionally and just tell you
crusades just happened out of the blue
five centuries of peace down the toilet
and now and now Muslims can you imagine
that when 9/11 and all that happened and
and until now when there's an Islamic
terror attack in Europe they try to
actually associate it to the crusades
and say well Muslims are still upset
about that they have grievances
Okay.
>> And they don't I mean because Muslims
are not idiots.
>> They actually respect the Crusades in
the sense that oh okay there was a time
when Christians fought back. Oh okay
good for them. [laughter]
But but I mean everything is being done
you know to just rewire everything so it
fits that narrative.